ibm named as a forester wave leader an
expanded partnership with github
and the general availability of ibm
cloud secrets manager
all on this episode of ibm cloud now
what's up y'all
my name is ian and i am back to bring
you the latest and greatest news and
announcements from ibm cloud
to kick this one off i want to share
some good news we recently received
ibm cloud pack for automation has been
named a leader in the latest forester
report
the forester wave ibm cloud pack for
automation is a modular
intelligent automation platform for
designing building
and running customer automation
applications the report evaluated the
intelligent decision capabilities
delivered as part of the cloud pack
and it received the highest possible
score in the strategy category
and among the highest scores in market
presence
these intelligent decisioning
capabilities are crucial because they're
helping clients to identify
opportunities to increase profitability
enforce consistency to improve
compliance and use
information to manage risk to read the
full report
and learn more about the cloud pack for
automation see the link i've got in the
description of this video
next up i'm excited to share that ibm is
expanding its strategic partnership with
github
to help companies automate work across
business users
developers and i t teams we are now
making it easier for our clients to use
ibm offerings with github
along three fronts the first is a
connector in ibm app connect
enterprise for github that will enable
enhanced interactions between software
development lifecycle tools
second the ibm urban code velocity
integration will expand
to include github issues and third the
watson ai ops integration will enable
automation of the work of sres
by leveraging data from github by
partnering with github
we're helping our customers unify their
devops and automation experiences
we're also affirming our commitment to
an open hybrid approach to devops
to learn more about the details of the
expanded partnership hit the link below
finally to close out this episode i want
to announce the general availability
of ibm cloud secrets manager with
secrets manager you can create secrets
dynamically
and lease them to applications while you
control access
from a single location as part of this
ga launch the service is now available
in our dallas
frankfurt and sydney data centers we're
also excited to announce the service to
service integration
between secrets manager and the catalog
management service
which means you can create and retrieve
all the secured cloud api keys you need
from your secrets manager instance to
help secure your ibm cloud developer
operations
each account is allowed one light
instance for free without any limits on
secret capacity
for a limited time when pricing plans
are released we'll let you know
so you can start planning the next phase
to learn more and get started with
secrets manager please see the blog i've
got linked below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm cloud now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered
make sure you explore the links in the
description of this video
2020 has been a heck of a year and
bringing you these episodes has been a
personal highlight for me
thank you for tuning in i hope you have
a wonderful holiday season
and we'll see you again with more
episodes in january of 2021
and again please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in the cloud
now
you